bello a tutti ragazzi e benvenuto questo
nuovo episodio di among us questo era
uno dei video che vorrei stato un po più
all'inizio quindi sono un appello che
hanno sfilato ma la partita secondo me
merita un sacco lo stesso valente
ragazzi buona visione e fatevi saprebbe
dei commenti cosa ne pensate
quindi l'esito è chi è che accoppiata
finale io è che noi siamo un accoppiata
finale ragazzi secondo me non abbiamo
giocato bene la prima volta ma adesso
sono la madonna
possiamo farcela veramente io e cesca
allora cerca potrei farla fuori però se
la faccio fuori il problema se faccio
fuori cesca il primo è che siamo soli
soli solido avere qualcuno che potra
posto a testimoniare che non sono con
cesca a capo lo avrei ucciso
se fosse stato un pelo cherici non avrei
ucciso non sono riuscito che noia può
ammazzare pietro ma non l'ho ammazzata
perché sta facendo la roba io seguo che
noia ragazzi a me io vado in vado vado
dove c'è la camera di sorveglianza
perché devo far fuori quelli che
osservano fisso proprio che non c'è
nessun nuovo invito calcoli da solo alla
prima a mettere la roba non posso fare
l'emergente avevano appena fatta che noi
e sta qua che noia sa conservare
bravissima ottima tattica siamo io che
noi gli siamo vicini vuoi fare fuori
qualcuno che noia ti prego dobbiamo
comunicare telepaticamente perché non
sto capendo vuoi fare fuori qualcuno
doveva io ti segue perché se di esperta
di me sono tutti qua sono tutti qua
quindi salvatrice a reactor
quindi se rimane qualcuno che noi
ammazzalo ma non esce non è rimasto
nessuno non siamo ancora riusciti ad
ammazzare nessuno io che noi e purtroppo
l'ho fatto fuori no maledizione rimasta
che noia intervento un vino potrebbero
esserci le telecamere magari qualcuno ha
visto tu sono morte se non mi hanno
visto ho fatto un culo finale se non mi
hanno visto cinque ok dominiamo anche
morto hanno una regalo da allora era
convinto grazie ancora sicuri di
personale anni chi lo ha seguito per
perché avevo una paura incredibile la
guardia del corpo trovato il cadavere in
medical è vero io non so niente di cosa
se posso dire che ho incontrato denso da
sola più volte non sono viva allora
eravamo a fare un esercizio
lorenzo charlie e cesca parola che
abbiamo fatto prima o poi la si anche
non ho fatto insomma che semplice ma
tutti prima di me quindi lasciato fare
secondo me nicky perché gioca detto
quindi presentati se nichi semi chi non
lavora seriamente loiero con leo ero con
leo che mi faceva la bosico e potreste
essere voi
nell'un come inizio va bene perché
abbiamo un po poteva andare meglio
perché l'importante che sia it impostori
vincono quando si accusa la gente da
sola però ed efficiente dobbiamo
studiarci un attimo meglio io che noi
dovremmo fare una doppia chi sarebbe più
proficuo visto che poi rimangono rimane
poca gente allora mammina
allora io l'ho però i tempi shaun island
quello perché bella amicizia e rovinate
capito
ai ragazzi è la cosa più bella che mi
rimangono miopi al tavolo guarda neanche
limito a dire cara bortone bottone no
c'è divergenza si abbatterà che noia
raga ma non lo stanno facendo
l'emergenza e mariga ma perché nessuno
andava su quella sopra quello
non ci sono mai arrivato fino a questo
punto deve capirlo
[Musica]
allora ragazzi adesso siamo
effettivamente chiumenti quindi sono
tranquillo se non che sappiamo che tu
faccia e gay su slot machine è che
cacchio te l'ho fatta grazie due ore per
tirare sta roba
oggi acer march che fa una tasca quindi
teoricamente non è lui
c'è qualcuno che sta guardando la le
telecamere ragazzini o chissà cosa le
telecamere io non lo sottovaluto sempre
importante ok perfetto abbiamo fatto
prima che ci facciano fuori i ragazzi
sottovaluto sempre le telecamere una
cosa che non si fa mai raga perché
purtroppo che ha posto hanno risolto se
non l ho ragazzi non sapete perché
purtroppo le telecamere sono infami
perché non ti accorgi mai che qualcuno
sta guardando di como stare attento al
puntino e del mac
adesso sta guardando nessuno ora sta
volando step non sta volando nessuno
sempre sempre guarda fisso le telecamere
ma le idee
no lo sapevo che era le 16 è previsto
hai visto cosa è successo
l'hai visto subito così fa vj security e
c'era ecco come allora io la gara molto
tirata no no no non ha neanche visto che
ce l'avevo di stef era qua io stavo 44
io sono molto e stefano l'ha visto
niente al gatto è stato pietro c'era
nulla il profumo madonna come il fatto
non accorgerti di chi è stato mannaggia
a theo bos ha fame seguì leo sto
maledetto un fame lo sapevo della leo
bellissimo perché nell'altro video va
bene mi fa incazzare mi ha sgamato
subito con che noia c'erano io che noi a
stefano ma mica anche noi a adesso che
era un chilometro e già sgamati stato
anche bravo ha detto che ci aveva un
millimetro perché stavo guardando le
minoranze non ha visto questa cosa non
l'ha certo mannaggia sto cercando di far
le tasche ragazzi cosa abbastanza
importante perché almeno sa almeno sento
di finirla però è colpa di billy leo
maledetto infami simo signori io vecchia
scattarsi ei start e ray la sigla del
grande fratello perché erano le
telecamere in diretta
l'assassinio e io mi spiace ma la gabbia
le sei rovinato
ma che cosa fare
capita che ha fatti vincere
bellissimo infatti vincere io forse
mancano solo un paio di tusk che non
vedo allora era da un po ero da un po le
telecamere non vedevo più passare gianni
e quindi mi sono messo a cercare il suo
cadavere
ok e l'ho trovato in navigation tutta
totalmente ma manca anche qualcun altro
a chi è l'altro lato nichi mitico ok no
anche mickey cassetto io posso dire una
cosa
esatto anche a me puzza ste perché
adesso sono sempre stato con con pietro
martire però ci siamo incontrati avrei
voluto dire che mi ha visto a fare due
emergenze ma nichi è morto quindi non è
una fusione è male emergenza abbiamo
fatto meno ossigeno e sequestri posso
fare anche i fantasmi e non ne ho fatte
un botto perché manca poco che finisce
io devo dire grazie alla persona in
questo gruppo adesso posso guardarmi
anche i talloni semplicemente girando il
collo ma io la tenterei anch'io io non
posso dire nulla andare a me che noi
avevi dove march più di sé doppia
abbiamo fatto tutte le mie passioni
cominciamo più o meno le stesse sono
cavoli e due killer da stata la razza
troppo l'andazzo
quelle di emergenza di quanta non posso
farlo
no no no infatti mancano solo quelle di
tanti ragazzi questo era il dobbiamo un
caso di oggi spero vi sia piaciuto e noi
come sempre ci vediamo lavoro
[Musica]